hi everyone its definition here with the
Aquaman Justice League saw a legion of
collectors box we're gonna say if the
box of this is better than the Justice
League box office see what I did there
kids so anyway we're opening it up got
you Justice League lads on Scott man and
it's got Wonder Woman it's got Superman
what's why does it look so funny
we've got got Steppenwolf one which I'm
really happy with he looks better than
he did in the movie and you're having
that cause of the Aquaman one yeah
that's all right in it's got a weird got
weird background on it you want to just
look over Matt over here on our wall
I've got all my Funko pops here so I'm
building up quite a collection of crap
you probably know this oh that's what
the straws for it was gonna be the last
straw when I seen that it was a [ __ ]
strong box so a Wonder Woman cut so yeah
quite happy with that so I must dash and
you get it cuz you like you had a
mustache check out my next video thanks
very much take care boots